turning overseas now to the latest on
the war in ukraine the country's
military says russian troops are now
inside this steel factory in mariupol
and difficult and bloody battles are
going on for control of the last
stronghold of the city's defenders
deborah powder reports now on ukrainian
soldiers and their allies including some
americans who have been hurt fighting
the russian invaders
the harder russia flexes its military
muscle the harder ukrainians fight back
and they've been joined by american
fighters like manus blinded by shrapnel
i can take it i'm young i'm a man i'm
strong
it's the kids and the old people
who i really worry about but they're not
just battlefield casualties
they are war heroes i was knocked out
totally
and woke up came round in
my intensive care unit vitaly
stanislavic owes his life to three
american volunteer fighters after their
vehicle was blown up by a landmine
alexis antilla also injured was the
first person to rush to him and feel for
a pulse i didn't think he was going to
make it in that moment but we still were
going to do everything we could to get
him out of the vehicle
instinct then kicked in for rob vardaro
and i refuse to let him die he's my guy
he's in my vehicle
um so i
because i knew i had no time to like
look where i'm stepping
i ran through the minefield they dragged
him from the burning vehicle
their quick thinking saved him
especially alexis she is medic
they put tourniquet on me because i was
bleeding like hell like hell so that was
very important
that probably saved your life it saved
my life for sure
they worked magic
miracle just
wonder and i don't know how they managed
to save my life and now he's worried for
their lives as they're fighting in the
east
i don't want something happen to them
yeah i want them to be alive yeah you
love them
it's more than love i can't imagine my
life without my saviors
a friendship forged on a bloody
battlefield which shows no signs of
letting up as russia continues its
all-out assault in the donbass region
russia may have ramped up its offensive
in the east but doesn't have much to
show after more than two months of
fighting it's only managed to capture
one city so far which is perhaps why
it's going all out in mario paul in a
bid to bring it fully under russian
control gail
all right deborah and all of the
americans who are volunteering there
thank you very much